- Let's talk about third
parties in the United States.
And I put the word
third in quotation marks
because there's more than one third party.
So you could even think
of it as a third, fourth,
fifth, sixth and seventh parties.
But the reason why
people say third parties
is because in the United States,
you have two dominant parties.
You have the Republicans
and you have the Democrats.
And so any other party is
considered to be a third party
after those first two
big, dominant parties.
So here are some of the
logos of some of the,
I would say, major third
parties in the United States.
And I'm gonna put major in quotes
because they don't have much of a say
in our government today.
You have the Libertarian Party,
that is very focused on
people's individual liberties.
They generally think about the government
doing as little as possible.
That whenever the government
strives to get bigger,
it infringes on people's liberties,
either in the economic sphere
or in the social sphere.
The Green Party is also
very pro-civil liberties,
but you can also imagine,
because it's called the Green Party,
it is very concerned with the environment.
Now, this third, third party,
and there's many more
than just these three.
This is the Reform Party.
And the Reform Party is really interesting
because it was started
by Ross Perot in 1995.
And this was after, in 1992,
Ross Perot ran as an Independent
candidate for President.
And he did surprisingly well.
He got nearly 20 percent
of the popular vote.
But an interesting question is
even though he got 20 percent
of the popular vote in 1992,
and even though in the Reform Party,
it had some reasonable support
even in the 1996 election,
how come we don't see Congress people
who represent the Reform Party?
And there's two real answers here.
One is, the winner-take-all system.
Winner - take - all.
So if we're dealing with a situation
where even if a third party
gets 20 percent of the vote,
they're not going to get
any representation for it.
And you can contrast that
with a proportional representation system
like you have in some Parliaments.
So in some countries,
their Parliament is elected
by proportional representation.
So let's say that 20 percent vote for
Party A.
Let's say 70 percent vote for
Party B.
And then the remainder, 10
percent, vote for Party C.
In a Parliamentary proportional
representation system,
Party C would get roughly
10 percent of the seats
in the Parliament.
But that's not the way it
works in our government.
In our government, in
almost any jurisdiction,
if you had a voter breakdown like this,
well, Party B would win.
Or maybe sometimes Party A would win,
and even if Party C does get some votes,
it's never going to cross the threshold
to actually get representation.
Now, with that said, this
doesn't fully explain
why we don't we see more
third party representation
in say the United States Congress.
Because there are countries that have more
third party representation,
even though they don't have
proportional representation.
Now another reason that's often cited for
why we don't see third
party representation
is that the major parties,
the Republicans and Democrats
oftentimes incorporate
the third party's messages
into their own.
To get a sense of this, I'm gonna show you
a little bit of an excerpt
from a Reform Party ad in 1996.
And at that time, they were saying things
that neither the Democrats
or the Republicans
were saying very strongly.
And I want you to think
about, when you hear it,
whether some of those
messages have, later on,
become parts of either the
Republican or the Democratic
candidate's messages.
- Washington is selling our
future to the special interests.
- Don't waste your vote on
someone who will sell you out.
- Ross Perot is the only
candidate who will work
- For our interests, instead
of the special interests.
- Just vote for Ross.
- Because you own this country.
- So as you saw in that
ad from the Reform Party,
there's a lot of talk about
the influence of special interests
and how people need to
take their government back.
And if you fast-forward to the
2016 Presidential election,
you had two major forces,
actually one on the Republican side
and one on the Democratic side.
On the Republican side,
you have Donald Trump,
who's echoing the need to
focus on special interests.
That Washington is a swamp,
that it needs to be drained.
It wasn't obvious from that ad,
but Ross Perot in 1992 was
ringing the alarm bells
about NAFTA and free trade and saying
why it would be bad for the United States.
And in 2016, you heard
many of these same things
from the Republican
candidate, Donald Trump.
Same thing with Bernie Sanders
on the Democratic side.
He echoed the need to take
a second look at free trade.
And that special interests
had taken over Washington.